- Fuck.
Get perspective.
We're so fuckin' lucky.
Stop crying.
I'm the biggest believe
in humans in a macro,
it's why we're still here.
But in the micro, it's hard
for us to get so excited
to eliminate plastic straws,
'cause turtles get choked by them.
Right?
It's just hard.
Or, stop eating this
thing that's delicious
in return for this thing
that's not delicious
because in 400 years it'll
be better for your great,
so what I would say is too much ideology,
more practicality, and
more short term benefits
are a very important starting point.
♪ This face I show is growin' old ♪
- [Gary] So our model is if you're a brand
that does a commercial, and
it costs $800 thousand dollars
in out of pocket and
creative, and production,
we try to convince that client to do
six or five or four or three
long-form Facebook videos
for that same cost,
which can first
fit different demographics.
Right?
Because when you do one commercial,
it's just vanilla.
Whereas, you know,
if you star an Asian
families in their 20's
and target Asian-American
or Europeans in their 20's,
you're gonna over-index in relevance.
Helsinki bound.
About to give this keynote.
- [Man] Why are you shaving his head?
- I'm shaving his head
'cause we're settling a bet.
Stockholm.
- 100 bucks for Finland's
100th anniversary.
- That's right.
- Baban couldn't find any equipment, so
- So, we're gonna show the
yeah, we settle the scores around here.
- So, get your
♪ Lights they come, they go, it's dark, ♪
♪ The show goes on and
they'll just wants a piece ♪
♪ I remember getting all this started ♪
♪ I was 12 years old ♪
- We made a bet to shave his head for
a hundred bucks.
He said, when you get to Helsinki,
we will take care of it.
So I'm gonna pull out my $100 dollars.
I've never shaved a man's head before, so
I hope this doesn't hurt you.
(laughs)
Good?
- Go for it, go for it.
- Alright, I'm gonna do the first cut,
then I'm gonna move you on over and
give this keynote, 'cause
that's what you're here for, but
you ready?
(audience applauds, cheers)
This is actually fun.
This is fuckin' awesome.
(audience laughs)
Some of the biggest things
I'm pushing right now
is be very aggressive in your 20's,
and try a lot of things.
Some people are naturally self aware,
and have a very clear
vision, others are still
trying to figure it out.
I think the answer, if I can bring value
to the most people here,
is if you have 100 percent conviction,
and you know exactly what
you're passionate about
and what you're good about, well then, go.
But if you have any doubt, early on,
this is where you can take the most risk!
Right?
What most humans do is start making money
and then start creating debt or overhead
that puts them into a box.
The beauty of being in your 20's is
you don't have money or stuff often,
so that allows you the freedom to try shit
and during an era like this,
trying shit around AI or AR or crypto,
Blockchain, is a great thing because
you may stumble on your passion
and what you're good at.
So, both can work.
It comes down to the individual.
Vlogging is not gonna stop.
There's no reason for it to stop.
People have an inherent
need to communicate.
It's who we are, it's
what we've done forever.
Drawing on caves, smoke signals, writing,
we communicate.
So vlogging is just beginning,
everybody will do it.
Where those videos are being consumed
will change through the years.
I think the next three or four years is a
Facebook, YouTube world.
And let me give you one
other piece of advice
if you're saying to yourself,
fuck, then what do I do?
You're never gonna know the alternative.
If you go in all in on a project,
you're never gonna be able to figure out
if you tried other things so
this is more about being optimistic
or pessimistic as a human being.
In 10 years, if you
didn't try something else,
even if you're successful
and you're a pessimist,
you're gonna make up in your own mind
that if you did something
else, it would've been better.
So I think this is
about making a decision,
and not dwelling or
pondering on 'what if'.
'Cause 'what if's cripple people.
99 percent likely it won't happen.
But if you're one percent
that's good enough
to actually execute, and get to the place
where you go global, then
you get to go global.
But nobody is global right away.
But everybody looks at Facebook and Uber.
Uber started in just San Francisco!
Uber, guys, Uber spent a year and a half
just trying to figure out San Francisco.
A year and a half.
Do you understand?
- A long time.
- Yeah, no it's not!
It's a long time in the way
that you're wired right now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- A year and a half is nothing!
- So, when I met you first time, 2011
- Yes.
- Right after that, I
founded my own agency.
- Yes.
- And watch out, don't
screw D-Rock's angle there.
(laughs)
I founded an agency, I
sold everything I had,
and my apartment on eBay
and today we are 12 people and about
one million Euro in revenue.
- Congratulations.
- What's the biggest mistake people do
where they are, where I am now?
- At this point?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I think they get impatient.
It took you all this time to get here,
now you got this nice little foundation,
and now you're saying, okay,
I'm gonna go from one million Euros
to five million, 10 million.
It's just the same old game,
it's no different than Joanna.
Everybody's mistake from
the beginning to the end
is lack of patience and practicality.
Everybody wants things too fast.
You were able to get here,
the answer for you to continue
in a client service business
is more of the same.
But what happens is,
people start getting loose
when they have money,
or when they're going
in the right direction.
So I think,
I mean, I think the thing
you need to continue to do
is continue to hone your craft
in whatever the agency does,
get more clients, and then also
keep an eye on any
technology that can disrupt.
The other mistake people make is
for example in 2009, the
mistake that people made
as a one million dollar agency was
they, because they made
their million on Google,
they disrespected Facebook.
Got it?
So, there's two mistakes people make.
One's offense, one's defense.
Going nice and slow is
defensive in some ways.
They try to become a rabbit
instead of a turtle, right?
And that's the mistake.
And then number two,
they disrespect what's
happening around them.
So, for me, I never play in the middle.
I'm very insular to what I'm doing,
and then I'm paying
attention the macro things
that can fuck up what I'm doing.
And I respect those energies
if they're bigger than me.
Competitors are not bigger than me.
Platforms are bigger than me.
Do you understand?
So I think those would be
the mistakes you might make.
- [Man] Thanks bro.
- [Gary] You got it bro.
Happy birthday.
- [Man] Thank you.
- [Man] I was talking to a Chinese couple,
and the male of the male female duo
asked me a very good question,
which I didn't really have an answer for.
But it was how
he's approaching it from
the largest sovereign state in the world
or whatever it is, right?
And there's 195, 200 of
these and one global system.
So, his question was,
where or how
how does a sovereign state,
with all its institutions
with all its mechanisms in place
effectively control, or
manage the tide of automation
that is on its way?
- You know, I think that
I think that we are
underestimating our ability
to find new things for people to do.
I mean, everybody said
that farming was the
infrastructure to our society.
You know, there was a time and age
when machines were
invented that eliminated
farming jobs.
And everybody said that
it would ruin our world.
Because everybody was a fuckin' farmer.
But then we did other shit.
For example,
David's career is to
film another human being
and travel with him.
This is not a career that I think
a lot of us knew existed 20 years ago.
- [Man] Or even what I
thought I would be doing.
- So I think that when
people start talking about
very heady shit like you're asking me
which is, what happens
when AI really hits scale
and we eliminate jobs?
Driver-less cars in America.
Truck driving is the number one job in
what happens?
They go find, to do something else.
This is what always happens.
There used to not,
people used to ride a horse.
And then a car was invented.
But the man was,
I was a horse person.
I drove a horse to get people around.
That's how I paid for my family's life.
Here's a car, oh my God.
Not oh my God, you did something else!
True entrepreneurs don't cry
about what they don't have,
they focus on what they do have.
And so, if you're in the Ukraine
and the rules of the
government and the ecosystem
are what they are, you deal with it.
You know, in the U.S., I'm an entrepreneur
that works 18 hours a day
and have sacrificed 20 years,
and I give up more than half of my income
to the government to
give to people who don't.
That's the rules of America.
You play within the rules of your game.
So, my biggest point of view
on humans analyzing humans
is that we underestimate us.
In parallel, here's what I think.
People dwell on, oh my God, AI's coming.
Meanwhile, so is space exploration.
Let's say, space exploration works.
Let's say all of us here actually
want to live on the moon.
Let's just play.
Do you know how much shit
we have to do up there?
I think there's enormous underestimation
of the human spirit.
It's how I think about terrorism.
If terrorism was as real
as people think it is,
there'd be a terrorist act with a car
driving through people in
London, Paris and New York
every day of the week.
It's unstoppable.
It's unstoppable to stop somebody
from getting into a car
and driving into a bunch of people.
We underestimate how
good the human spirit is
and how capable the human spirit is.
Since 1950, there's been a human
that's had the ability to blow
up the whole fuckin' place.
I mean,
so, to answer your question,
very easily.
Because what humans do,
not sovereign states
is find other shit to do.
So if you work at a fuckin'
telemarketing station
right now, and AI's gonna
answer all those questions,
and you're not gonna have a job anymore,
you're gonna find a different job,
like following somebody
around with a camera.
(reflective music)
We haven't done a solid
Airport Gary in a while.
But it's warm here in Finland.
Oh!
That I want.
Woof!
♪ Pain gets washed away ♪
♪ Seeds will grow away ♪
- [Gary] There's so many of you that have
but you're at a crossroads,
there's confusion in the system,
it doesn't feel the way you want it to.
Do something about it.
The answer to answer to every single thing
running through your
dome right know is "so".
So?
What are you gonna do about it?
Because the reality is, it's halftime.
And halftime adjustments are sexy.
Real good.
(inspirational music)
To me, buying,
doing something to get some money,
then going and buying
things that are underpriced
and then selling them,
and if we have technology,
eBay, Facebook Marketplace, Craigslist
or at a flea market,
that is literally something
everybody on Earth can do.
(video game music)
- [Man] We're live.
- [Gary] We're live?
- [Gary] Alright.
Where's my fuckin', where's my chat
got caught.
(laughs)
I need my fuckin'
can you put, you can't put the chat,
where's the chat?
- Right up top.
- I know but what about,
what is this?
I don't understand, I
feel like I don't like
shit like that.
(8 bit music)
- Keep, keep!
- Russia!
Russia!
- Woo!
- Russia!
Let's go, Russia!
(exclaims, laughs)
Let's go!
- Ahh!
Fuck!
How do you?
Alright.
(laughs)
- I lived that life.
I lived it a whole entire game.
- I don't know how to bury it!
My keeper's the M-V-fuckin'-P!
(laughs)
- Let's go!
(claps)
Let's fucking go, Twitch!
(laughs)
Come see me, ninja!
Set Free, tell 'em!
- Twitch world we brought
the winners get gifts over here.
So we're presenting Gary with a trophy.
You know he's blossoming
in the world of tech,
media, social, entrepreneurship.
- This is fuckin' amazing.
Tell everybody what this is about.
Tell 'em about that talent!
- Sponge Bob
marijuana plant.
And you can see Sponge Bob has
he's feelin' really good.
It's a collaboration between
myself and Ron English
and made by Monsters.
So we had to hand deliver it to Gary.
We got three different versions.
- I got the gold one?
- Yeah we got a gold one
- So break down the numbers.
This
came out, sold out?
- Sold, gold sold out first.
- And how much,
let's start with this.
This, how many units?
- 500 of them.
- 500 units of this.
Sold out.
- Sold out.
- And how much was this?
- 650, all of them sold out.
If anybody could open
the other ones for us.
So we, you got the whole set.
- 650 on this one.
- Yep.
And the other two is
called Ganja Grin Gold
and Ganja Grin Silver.
- So, tell everybody
about the Charlie Brown,
'cause I think that really
established your foundation.
Yes.
- So,
what happened was the world,
I grew up looking at
cartoons and I was like,
yo, there are no African
Americans cartoons,
so I created a black Charlie Brown figure.
Made him two different color ways,
one black, gold, one with silver.
And it sold out a success.
We did 600 pieces, sold
out in three minutes.
And this is our third toy.
And this one is
- This is the gold.
- The gold
- This is crazy.
This is crazy.
- That was the first one to sell out.
- And how many of these were made?
- 150 each of these.
- And how much was this?
- All of them was 650.
- 650.
- Yep.
And then this is the
- Silver?
- Silver.
And he's called Pot of Gold,
he's called Silver Haze.
- Fuckin' fresh.
- So all of y'all
everybody that's watching Twitch,
inhalin' and exhalin',
we're gonna leave it
at, parental guidance.
(mashing controller buttons)
Ooh, what a pass!
- That was a good give and go!
- A'ight.
- Let's go!
Look at that big league jumper!
- Not bad, 10 to 6.
- Alright.
(mashing controller buttons)
Pop that three!